Je croyais que vous devriez traiter les
gens comme vous voulez être
traité Jésus n'a-t-il pas dit que
tout prenait toujours une faveur par rapport à l'argent Je
pense que Jésus a dit cela aussi mais je
ne sais pas qu'il a dit qu'est-ce que c'est le plus tôt
tout le monde  je pensais que tous les muscles de
Rasheeda resteraient au bureau je suis dehors avec
l'impression que je suis des gens qui travaillent pour moi
mes idées je dirige le spectacle sur le
quart-arrière et je ne vais pas régler
ce n'est pas à moi de dire qu'il était  'pas
forcément en forme et il avait
ce peigne dessus qui était plutôt élaboré
il avait cette confiance qui m'a attiré vers
lui mon père il m'a appris à croire
que tout le monde est bon et à être bon
avec tout le monde la vie est ridicule et tu
sais  que je ne dirais jamais rien de mal à
propos de ton père devant toi mais
ton père est un fils de merde malade somme
de [ __ ] ne répète pas ça mais oui hé
joue un rôle salut tu peux
tu dois trouver un moyen de  survivre et
tu savais que tes choix étaient mauvais mais tu
devais survivre nous pouvons s  o réussi pendant
si longtemps parce que nous l'avons gardé juste
assez petit si vous avez tant de succès comment
se fait-il que vous vous retrouviez dans cette pièce avec moi en
ce moment à prendre des ordres de moi
son agent DiMaso plaçant soixante-quinze
mille dollars dans cette mallette pour le
maire carmine polito
je  Je vais faire un tour, est-ce
qu'on doit oublier tous ces gars,
c'est ce à quoi nous devons penser en
ce moment, nous devons oublier tous
ces gars, elle doit être la meilleure que nous ayons
jamais faite